Hi. Hi, Rain Wilson. Hi, Angela. Hi, Jenna. Hi, office ladies. Thanks for joining us. Yeah. And you're probably wearing your Seattle Seahawks hat. I'm representing. Yeah. Also, I haven't taken a shower yet, so my hair is matted. I wasn't sure if we were recording video, like for social media purposes or whatever. So we're not. No worries. Your bedhead is safe with us. Excellent. It's good to see you guys remotely. You look great. Do you have a Michael Scarn threat level midnight poster over your shoulder?
I do, yes. It's one of my few kind of office memorabilias. I've just got a Michael Scarn poster. Yeah, I probably hang it. It looks signed. No, it's not signed. I suppose I could get it signed. I know the guy, Steve Correll,
who played Michael Scarn. So I suppose I could get it signed. It's very cool. Even that Krasinski fellow, although he's kind of busy in New York. Goldface. He's not. not signing it. Golden face? Is that his name? Golden face. Yeah. I think I could probably talk to his
publicist's manager and see about getting a signature. Good luck with that. What's going on? What are we talking about? What's happening? What's happening with Office Ladies? It's been a long time since I've been on the show. You guys, congratulations on the success and everything you're doing and your media empire. It's beautiful. Thank you, Ray. Last time you were on Office Ladies, it was because I recorded you from the back of my car after we had lunch. So thank you for that. It was about food. It was about food. Yes. Now we're doing something special on Fridays. We do it once a month. It's called Friday Chit Chat. I'm so happy to be here, although you do kind of need a theme song for Friday Chit Chat. You think, Chit Chat. I feel like Ed Helms could write a really good Friday Chit Chat.
You are not wrong. That would be amazing. We should reach out to Ed. Let's get him on that. Well, here's how it works. We put a call to action to our fans out there who love office ladies. And we just said, what do you want us to chit-chat about? And they send in suggestions and we've got a great one this week. Jenna. Yes. Jenna, I hate to break it to you.
No one listens to this show. Oh, no. They don't. You don't have fans. Rain, that's AI bots or something. No one listens to office ladies. Well, this suggestion, Rain, we do. This is coming from.
Jenna F. and Angela K from Los Angeles. Wow. I'd love to hear from Jenna F and Angela K. Jenna F and Angela K write in a lot. They're big fans. Okay, here is our chit-chat suggestion of the week. It comes from Audrey W. Audrey says, I've seen posts about which office character would you rather be stuck camping with. So I was wondering, who would you like to be stuck camping with for three days and why? Well, that's a great question.
I mean, there's so many different ways you could go. I have a request. I would like us to say which office character we want to be stuck camping with and then which of us in real life we want to be stuck camping with. I like where you're going with this. I like where you're going. I definitely know which office character would be the most fun. And I'm a little bit biased because immediately as you read the question, I was like, oh, there's an episode here. And that would be Dwight and Andy camping together or being forced to camp together
and just total opposites on the campground. I don't know if that's what the question was. I just kind of put myself in Dwight's shoes. But I think it would be so much fun because Andy would have like the perfect tent from like LL Bean, you know, and his stove and like a solar panel and like a drone that, you know, can bring in food. And he'd have a freeze-dried ramen and pot stickers and gourmet food. And then Dwight would just have like a loincloth and a knife and like a tent made out of a Buffalo hide or something like that. That would be such a good episode, don't you think? It would.
And I feel like Andy would make up a campfire song and it's like the whole thing. He'd have brought a travel banjo. Yeah. And he would have a smore. kit that was like a really high-end R-E-I-Somor's kit. Oh, and tons of sunscreen. He'd have tons of sunscreen that's probably harmful to the environment, just like spraying it all over.
For three days, these guys. And he'd have an elevated tent that like the bottom inflated and brought them off the ground. But I think that an episode with Dwight and Andy camping would be, we kind of had that with Survivor Man with Dwight and Michael, but. Michael, yeah. I think that would be really fun to watch the opposites. And then Dwight goes and, you know, kills a fawn with a hunting knife. And like Andy's peaking.
He's peaking in the woods. I would watch that episode. Would you as Rain Wilson want to go camping with Dwight or Andy? Well, Dwight would definitely be more of an adventure. But since I'm a little bit more of the indoor type, I like some camping sometimes. But I think that Andy would be great. It's just entertainment, technology, comfort. I'm going to go straight up with Andy.
Final answer. Andy Bernard, final answer. Andy on both Dwight and Rain. Yeah. What about you, Ms. Fisher? What about me? I thought about this. I really did.
And I thought about who I don't want to go camping with. I don't want to go camping with Dwight. Just too intense. I also think I would not want to go camping with Jim, doesn't he seem like not a great camper? You know who I think I would want to go camping with is maybe, hear me out, Roy. Doesn't Roy seem like he's going to carry a lot of heavy shit and he's going to put up the tent? Doesn't he say like maybe he's a good outdoorsman? I think if a bear came along, he's definitely getting in the middle of me and a bear. Like, I trust that. Yeah, I feel like Roy has gone
hunting with his like cousins and stuff, like has a deer stand somewhere. I mean, the downside is he's probably drinking late into the night. But the other person I was going to say that I would go camping with is Karen. I think Karen would be super fun to camp with. Oh, interesting. You know, she's smart. She's funny. We would have similar interests. We'd go hiking, but then we would have a little rosé by the fire in the evening. I just, I feel like that would be like a really good vibe. And finally, my last group of people I would want to go camping with in real life, in real life, like Jenna has now gone camping with Roy and Karen.
I would also go camping me and Lee with Michael and Holly. I would go couples camping with Michael. I would. I think they'd be fun. I mean, Michael in his just like childlike, wonder of the world, I think could be fun to camp with and entertaining. I mean, three days is a long time. I think they would do a lot of voices.
Yeah, I think on like day two when they're going like, I like a piece of picat, I. You're right. And they're like doing all their voices. Maybe it's too much. Yeah, three days is a bit much. But I got to jump in here, Jenna. I'm so sorry. What is it? Well, first of all, Roy, like, first of all, you have to hang out with Roy for three days.
Yeah. what are you going to talk about with Roy? And number two, you just talked about how Roy would defend you from a bear. You have Rain Wilson on your show. And you're talking about how Roy would be the best one to defend you from a bear. Are you kidding me? Okay. Here's the thing. Come on. I'm offended. I'm deeply offended. I need someone who will defend me from a bear, but also be pleasant to camp with. So I feel like, yes, Dwight will protect me, but am I going to enjoy the rest of the three days? No. He's, going to have me up at like 4.45 a.m. on some expedition, some quest. Like, no, Roy is sleeping in. And also, if Roy doesn't talk to me, who cares? I'll read a book. You know what I mean? I think Karen's a good way to go because interesting conversationalist. Pretty chill, but capable. Exactly. She'll help carry stuff from the car. Smart. Yep. All right. Well, I'm going to throw something at you guys. Okay. I would go camping with Joe Bennett. Really? because I think she goes full glamping.
And I don't want to poop in the woods, okay? I want some type of like fashion toilet situation. Dwight is a survivalist, no doubt about it. He can build a structure. He can do the things. I don't want to wipe with a leaf, you know? I don't want any of that. But I feel like Joe Bennett, she would have a staff that would go ahead of us and set up the tent.
And like we'd probably have like these really nice chairs by the fire. I want to glamp with Joe Bennett. That's what I want to do. For three days. She'd probably use her dogs as pack animals. Yes. We would ride her dogs. We're not very tall. Yeah, you're small enough. You'd be on one dog. The other dog would be carrying your toilet and your toilet paper. Yeah, please. So you don't have to use a leaf and a log. I don't want to use a leaf in a log. That sounds horrible. And then in real life, I think Creed Bratton would be a blast to go camping with. You guys, he goes fishing with his son. Also, he's obsessed with the TV show alone. He turned me and Josh onto it. Like, we've gone over
and watched it with him. So, like, I know that Creed knows how to, like, probably by this point, trap a rabbit. Hook a fish. Build a shelter. He can definitely fish. He's very good at fishing. And, you know, he would have campfire songs and crazy-ass stories that you wouldn't know, are these true or not? You know, he can spin a yarn. I think that's a great answer. And Creed is always the best dance. Whenever I go to like fan events or something and someone's like, who would you rather blah, blah, blah with? I just throw Creed in there because I give Creed some love and he's so fascinating. But you're right. You would have three hours guaranteed entertainment every night at the campfire with Creed, no doubt. Songs, stories, monologues, dances. He also does yoga every day.
So he would probably like bust out some yoga that we would all do in the morning. And he takes naps. I'm all for a nap. He goes to bed early. I think this is a really good camping partner. Wow. I don't think there's a better answer than Creed in real life. Yeah. He'd be so tickled too.
Is there like a prize for this? Does she win? Does she have a prize? Wait, do I win a signed threat level midnight poster by John Christop? You do. You do. I want to throw something out there. I want to go away from the cast for camping because you've convinced me on Creed, but otherwise,
I don't really want to go camping with any action. actor because I just, I'm sorry. Jenna, how dare you? How dare you? We would have so much fun. We might. We might. But we're all getting eaten by the bears.
Rain, I've always said that Jenna and I should do an amazing race. We'd be horrible. I would love to see you guys on an amazing race. That's a great idea. For real. You'd be so good. Who is doing the physical challenges? Who's like ziplining down the side of the mountain between me and Angela?
And I don't like. to eat weird things, Rain. If they say one of us has to eat like an ostrich egg to win, that's not happening. I can't. Is that happen an amazing race? Sometimes. Every once in a while, you have to eat like a scorpion or something. Are you eating a scorpion, rain? Yeah, I'd eat a scorpion. I went on bare grills. That's right. Wilderness. What's bear grills? Wilderness. Are you kidding, it's so good. It's like he's a crazy, amazing, like, surviving. guy and Rain went on it and so did Ed. Oh, you have to watch it. Rain, did you like it? What was that experience like? I had a blast. But yeah, Bear Grills is this survivalist, former like,
UK Marine guy and he's a great TV host and it's called Running Wild, I think, is the show. And yeah, we went out into the Utah wilderness. But the scariest thing about doing it was he strapped me to a helicopter. So when I got picked up by the helicopter, I had to ride on the skids on the outside of the helicopter and I was chained and we were zooming 100, 200 feet over the trees at like 50 miles an hour. And I have a fear of heights and it was brutal. But worse than that, when I got picked up at the end of it, they lowered a winch with a
cable and then they dragged me up into the air. So I was dangling by 100 feet under a helicopter and then it took off over the mountains. That was nuts. That was absolutely nuts. I think I might have had a bowel movement of some kind because that's just what is going through your mind right then? Yeah. How do you get through that?
It goes beyond terror where you're just like, okay, I guess I'm going to die and there's not really anything I can do. I mean... This is how I go out. I guess this is it. This is it. and you're just flying around, and you're just going one breath at a time. And it was absolutely brutal.
It was brutal. But we did, that made the cliff climbing, and I ate rot grubs. And, you know, I did a cold plunge in an alpine lake at like dawn and a zip line. That was all cakewalk compared to being strapped to a helicopter. The grubs thing was so gross. I mean, it's so gross to me. Like, I would have puked. They taste like people.
Peanut butter. Really? Yeah, the grubs, little grubs taste like peanut butter. Yeah. All grubs taste like peanut butter? You've had more than one type of growth? Are they protein forward? Because I'm really looking to up my protein.
You are not eating grubs, Jenna. I think it's the future. It's, you could have a grub farm. Talk to Creed. I think he grows his own. He grows his own rot grubs. He's got a little thing on his patio. I want to pitch something.
Maybe the two of you should go on Amazing Race, Not me and... Oh, Rain and Green and Angela. What? Angela, why are me and you going on Amazing Race together when you partner with Rain and he'll eat all the grubs and he'll do all the stunts? What am I breaking? You're reading the map and you're like keeping things positive. You just didn't look good, babe.
Oh, thanks, babe. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. You guys would be a good team. You would. It would be very entertaining. It'd be such a...
hot mess. Rain would call me like a cousin fucker and we'd run out a diet Coke. What if the accountants went on the amazing race? What if we all teamed up with our love interests and we competed against each other? So you've got Steve and Amy, got the two of you, me and John team up. Who else have we got, Mindy and BJ? We've got Oscar and the senator. Oscar and the senator, yes. Maybe Craig and David Denman could be a team. Oh, wait. What have been? about Hunter and Jan. Yes, Hunter and Malora. There we go.
You guys, that would kill. Somebody calls CBS. Phyllis and Bob Vance. Yeah. There you go. That's so good. It would be amazing. There it is.
That would get really good ratings, at least for the first one. You guys, I never got a chance to say who I would go camping with in real life, who isn't a cast member. And I want to say, and I think you're going to agree with me, that it's Randallinehorn. Our DP. Yeah. Oh, yeah. And beloved director. Yeah. Our DP and frequent director, who was a whitewater rafting enthusiast and has traveled the world and
hiked the outback. Yeah. He started on Survivor. In fact, our camera crew, you know, frequent office lady listeners are going to know this, but Matt and Randall are frequent directors and DPs started on Survivor because Greg wanted that immediacy of the cameras capturing the reality of the workers and wanted that that look and feel. And they ended up being just so integral to the look and feel of the show.
But Randall, slam dunk. Thank you. Randall, Sam Dunk. Also, Matt Sone. He hikes up crazy. And he was also like, you know, super outdoorsy camera guy. He's sinewy. I bet he can like get into.
He's sinewy? You know, like he can climb things. And I one time he invited me to go for a hike. This was years ago. And I was like, oh, I'm so tired. I don't know. And then he was hiking. He had his kid, like, who was like toddler size, like in a one of those backpacks that the kid, like, rides in.
And I was like, yeah, I'm the one being like, I'm kind of tired. And he's like carrying another person on the hike. He should have put you in the backpack. No, you know, just like Dwight and Angela. Your American doll size. That's what we do an amazing race is we have like a kid's backpack and I carry you. Yes. The entirety of the amazing race.
That's it. And I like have like water with a long straw that. I like feed you as we go. Yeah. Camelback. Yeah. Yeah. I think you just urinate into a satchel, kind of like in Dune, and then the urine is processed
into water, and that's what I drink. I'm essentially drinking your urine. It's all recyclable, you guys. That's amazing. So smart. You never have to rest. Just like in Dune. I bet you guys haven't even seen Dune, have you?
Of course I have. Are you crazy? I have, I have, like, teenagers. Dune is so good, Jen. Is it like Star Wars? Doon 2 is even better. No. Oh, like, Dune 2 was fantastic.
It was so good. I tried to watch it and it was like 20 minutes of just, it was just so slow moving and sand and I didn't understand anything. Oh my God. I'm sorry. I'm sorry. Who was the woman who hosted the Golden Globes, Nikki Glazier? Yeah.
Did you see her mind? Did she not like June? Did she say the same thing? Oh my God. Her monologue is so funny. When you're done with this, go watch Nikki Glazer's monologue. It is so funny. Does she go off one, too?
But she goes like, Hans Zimmer is here. Congratulations at Hans Zimmer because he did the soundtrack up to Dune. And she's like, my favorite song of yours is the one that goes, she's very funny. Oh, man. Get her on office ladies. We should. Yeah. Nikki, come on. All right, so everyone, we're going to watch Rain's Bear Grills and Eds, and now we're going to watch Nikki's opening monolog.
And Dune 1 and 2. And why not watch Rain's new movie that's out on Hulu called Code 3? Code 3. Okay, I've seen Rain's new movie Code 3, and it's excellent, Rain. It's truly excellent, and you're so good in it. It's so funny, but it's more than funny. And here's my pitch. If you like the TV show The Pit, this is the paramedic version of the pit, but also funnier. Yeah. So it's like comedic, the pit, but paramedics. That is a great pitch, Jenna. I want to watch that. Rain, I'm sorry.
It's in my cue. I'm sorry. It's a whole day. It's like one shift, one long shift as a paramedic. Your character's last shift, you're going to get out of the paramedic life, and I won't say anymore. And I'm training a new rookie paramedic. Yeah.
Who is great. Who is that actress? She's great. Amy Carrero. Amy Carrero. The whole cast is great. Lowrell Howrie. Rob Wrigal.
There's an office connection. Rob Riggle. Captain, what's his name? Captain Bob? Captain Bob. Captain Jack. Captain Jack. Captain Jack.
Rob Riggle plays a really assholy doctor in the emergency room. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Well, everybody, go see Code 3. folks are loving it. And, Rain, thank you so much
for being on Friday chit chat with us. I love you guys so much. This has been such a pleasure. Thanks for having me. We love you. Yay. You have to come back for...
Shut up. Shut up. Jenna F. already commented how much she loved this episode. Yes. She wrote in. And she said,
I love this episode so much. She said... Oh, look. Here's a new comment from Crean B. Creasy. He says, yes, I do have grubs. Angela Kay has also hearted this and given it a thumbs up and a little lady running in the red dress. So she really enjoyed this episode.
Nice use of emojis. All right, everyone. Come back, Rain. Come back anytime. Love you. Bye. Bye, guys. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbicoe. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis.
Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Bill Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertry by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.